hurt by a jerk better call burke today
we are joined by local personal injury
attorney
christopher burke owner of the patriot
law firm chris how are you today
hey rocky bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
getting ready to watch our run and
rebels uh play their first game coming
up at raiders stadium i'm very excited
all right let's discuss the case you had
recently against a hotel for personal
injuries from a fall
due to a broken chair yeah we're gonna
we're gonna do a case study on a case we
were recently retained on by a client
that fell
due to a broken chair in a hotel and
caused some pretty serious injuries
that is terrible what happened well our
client
70 years old uh checked into their hotel
as they got to their room in the hours
right as they got to their room
they were changing clothes and they sat
down in their chair
and the chair broke it actually broke
underneath them so our client went
tumbling down landed on his shoulder and
unfortunately had some pretty serious
rotator cuff injuries
had to have surgery so whose fault is
this exactly
well interestingly when i conducted some
discovery
i did some depositions we found out that
that chair in the room
was actually over 10 years old it had
been used thousands of times
even worse there appeared to be some
repairs to the chair before but we're
done with some
cheap particle board needless to say
after discovery
the attorneys for the hotel were really
wanting me to settle the case with them
in mediation
and chris what else did you find out in
regards to this case well we also talked
to some of the employees
that worked at the hotel specifically
ones that would come and check the rooms
these employees were supposed to check
if there was anything wrong with the
rooms
chairs that needed repair things like
that anything that would be a dangerous
condition in the room
and unfortunately the employee that we
talked to
said that they gave notice to their
managers about this room and about this
chair
but they didn't do anything give
christopher burke a call at the patriot
law firm that number is 702-620-2020 or
visit their website
at fightforthelittleguy.com